ladies and gentlemen the creative
director of the Last of Us Neil
druckmann and the men will be producing
the last best movie the one of these
might be
all right thanks start with you know we
heard screams when we first approached
us and
we wanna make a film version of last of
us was like well can we run it yes
can we have final say on casting yes and
we have final say on director yes so
like we're kind of given the keys to the
kingdom is like well that's on us so
let's hopefully Menominee and said Sam
yeah I was the companies that they said
no to this but in the story he said if
you companies came in they said no to
you but then they'd call pepper came in
and clean under the power to really
protect the great vision that I think
we're all so attracted to him in the
character Callie goes on this fantastic
attorney and fond of it and the
character patrol falls in love with the
east fighting against is decided upon
though because he's been so moved in 20
years ago it's just such a great movie
and I think little pepper other people
would try said I realized if the keys to
the kingdom and Emile's words were to be
in the right hands and he'll you know
Satan and his team invited up so I think
we're really going to make a great
picture that's why we're here so many
years early to announce it because I
have so much made that I feel it's going
to be a great character journey really
great boat story and really great work
I'm super excited you see obviously a
lot about video game adaptations
informant most of these sort of 80
characters and maybe take the setting
that the story ends are paying something
kind of completely else what what are
you guys doing how close are you going
to give you the original story here of
The Last of Us victus to start by saying
and what's unique is in Neal's reading
the script I don't think that's ever
happened before that the regular video
game you can actually read the screen
mrs. Rieder take the strengths
well
that's gonna be his partner what about
the you came out good left behind
expansion story for the inset something
that potentially could include the
gamers F just gonna sort of stings own
fingers elements of Left Behind that
could be pulled into the story mr. kg I
know you guys are really early with
Venice and but I mean obviously you've
mentioned it the story this is a story
between two people Joel and Ellie and
you've grown through the game you saw a
little bit up there on the screen is
super important
Wow is there my thirst
III I'm aging myself and I wait in line
with my brother for three hours to get
my DVD of army of Darkness director's
cut
and I've been holding up I'm like don't
bring it to work don't have somebody
sign it professional I'm sure that you
guys have already started to envision in
certain scenes or moments from this game
and be thoroughly excited a little
challenge in terms of how could we adapt
that I'm really excited to see how we're
going to turn this from the video game
up to the big screen or well this is
gonna pose a really big challenge there
any certain scenes moments characters
have you think that you guys can think
about writing with this process I'll say
there's something great strengths in the
game but I think the real job is to
recognize and it's more than a cutting
job
what would you can't be put in what is
not import of the relationship what's
put in work for gameplay or was a
situation that was put in for the
audience to really have a great video
game versus a great movie and the
strength of great movies are the
relationships the people you follow into
watching come friends what you've all
known with each other and that's what's
at the heart of again so I hope we just
push that further and I think that was
saying is he's working on the script
that seems to be his instincts to
release or focus those relationships
develop and hopefully the octaves were
bringing a real
another they are nothing that's not
they're already great actors form the
voices directors actors us we can bring
a little something that
animation sometimes can
movie they could really delve into your
soul this is the raw material that's
actually like there's all these new
seeds and our scenes and I'm really
they're really about combat encounter
with breathing we're going to open this
up to questions in just a minute so I'm
starting from custom questions for
produce and I guess Monday to start with
you
pretty different with the story and Dean
but it's still gonna be charming so we
gotta step pieces
yeah thanks sir I appreciate that I
think the key is to have their own
interpretation of the lines and the
moments and grades like if we try
imitating one-to-one like that all the
England then we'd be just a poor
invitations
well how about plan gives a lot of
first-person shooter games but how
simply a German Paris was trying to give
anything
- pressure on joelly and all the
surrounding caste so they have to make
really difficult choices and that's kind
of approach and running a film is like
that's not right just set pieces where
you run
affected and you know shooter is like
how is this moment applying pressure
causes moment telling us something new
of the bond between Joel and Ellie and
that's kind of like the test of whether
a sequence of spanks last of us to water
Oh turn movie is coming out 2016 there
was a compound as far as my cast I've
heard some things that I can say so I
can't sing
that's the list beyond two souls who was
out - I was wondering if Ellen Page
kind of like a big fan of all our films
what do you think so I wonder you know
Joe's daughter diamond
firstly the review
I was wondering if she would be moving
it that reveals too much Sam told me and
one of the things I was trying to change
was the opening and he really encouraged
like it really hurts me too we actually
talked about that no and I mean ideal
world Ashley Johnson would be 14 but
she's not but I think there's there's
ways to get those actors into the film
and I think in some way and it has to be
a part of it what do you think we're
rushing to rate her motion capture
performance was so great and you can't
imagine
anybody else but it's probably like that
when you have a great actor and they get
a great play it's better it's a
screenplay with stage play and then the
reality is that the plane that goes down
to another city like it goes to Broadway
them some of those actors can make it
and some can for different reasons that
they read sometimes previous commitments
sometimes the director seasoned
different aspect of them but I I think
the truth is that she probably couldn't
play the part consists of a little girl
and she doesn't look at the other part
so the otherwise I don't know I think
it'll be a casting process we'll find
the best people go go maybe they will be
need some of the rituals aspects from
the game
the doctor said it's so tough we're
gonna turn they look great picture
one really great picture really stress
the audience and makes me want to see
another and then I think it would be
completely up to Niels or another great
stories aren't they need to tell they
really wanted to tell them right and if
it was as powerful as the first them
encourage you to write hey since the
game just came out late last year do you
guys feel like it's too soon we do
business or well this besides I don't
answer that question for anything else I
think I would say it's too soon but I
have so much faith in this being a great
movie that's coming out a really
excitement about it and the Neil's doing
it and then Clinton called pepper has
really wanted us to not let anybody mess
it up that I really want to come here
early and say hey guys to say it's
coming in I think it's gonna be great
because in fact I'm gonna fan myself and
when someone really believes you
something
you know I believe in this gonna be
fantastic so I don't think it's too
early it's like I felt the same way
about people down although people do
where they feel that way at the time and
I felt the same way about spider-man
it's really gonna be cool I wanted to
tell people it's time so I didn't think
it was too early to say that great
project yeah one of the things for us
when we took on this project we asked
himself that as well but the thing that
was kind of intriguing to us is we feel
as developers and gamers there's never
been a great video game adaptations film
there's been some stuff there enjoyed
nothing is like and like what if we
could make the first great work and I'm
not saying we will we're gonna try
really hard we're gonna work our house
house it's going to make this thing
great and really capture the bond
between gentlemen so that was kind of
like why why wait let's just we have an
opportunity with a great apartment to go
to school also part of a producer's job
is the second great bar of expectation
that not just for the redness and the
directors to come in the office but for
the studio there's 100% behind the
project but it's my job to say this
thing is gonna be great to put on your
radar we're gonna rise to the
expectation and meet transportation and
hopefully exceed it so just for the fans
it's for me it's for the entire ministry
to to learn abilities coming in but the
best directors out there know that they
may be a chance to drag this really fine
picture you know you've been so involved
knowing this is a
a matter of the supernatural
what's a consummate how deep this is my
world I'm gonna return to tell me into
the unknown the deepest parts that I'm
most attracted to the game and the
horror side and the emotional side for
those of you who haven't played the game
yet maybe there are many of you I'll
just say the most about the endings but
the emotional connection
between joelly when it's always
unexpected it's always moving in a new
direction
it seems fighting against it those
moments of human attraction conflict
that is so beautifully defined this game
that's what the track so that's my
favorite ones
you